and then yesterday robert de niro he was
asked about the success of the roseanne
reboot he took a shot at the president
and said quote we're at a point with all
of this where it's beyond trying to see
another person's point of view there are
ways that you can talk about that but
we're at a point where that the things
that are happening in the country are so
bad and it comes from Trump there are so
many people who have left this
administration it's a serious thing so I
don't care about Roseanne well sounds
like De Niro wasn't happy that there
finally is a TV show that actually
appeals to Americans that they actually
want to watch the reaction the author of
the best-selling book vengeance
he's been incognito he's been missing in
action former Speaker of the House Newt
Gingrich welcome back sir how are you
well it's good to be with you and the
fact is we're in the middle of a
cultural civil war and the language is
the language of a civil war
people say horrendous things and they
mean them you know I think on the left
level of hostility at every single zone
if you if you look at people like Marco
Rubio being charged with he's and he's
responsible for murder if he takes money
from the NRA I mean this is the kind of
horrific language that makes it
impossible to bring people together
because they really are that far apart
yeah so the president is not a target we
learned that and we know that the
Washington Post even reporting all right
the the Muller is unlikely to indict
Trump a sitting president collusion
isn't a crime and I'm watching all this
unfold and he's gonna issue a series of
reports on all of this and then we see
this whole other side where Hillary
steals a primary then Hillary has the
fix if we know she deleted acid-wash
subpoenaed emails breaks up you know
different devices all that happens then
chief we find out takes a year we find
out she's the one that paid for the
phony Russian dossier you have the
cover-up of the crime she committed with
Comey struck page mccabe and and of
course Loretta Lynch and then they lie
to a FISA Court he's we have real
evidence and real proof no evidence of
Trump Russia collusion but that's all
the rest of the media talks about
and then of course the president has a
lot of success stories nobody talks
about that either
why why don't we go back to a very
simple model we're a very learn a
cultural civil war if you are the left
you never talk about your size
weaknesses and you never acknowledge the
other side strengths and of course
what's happening to the left is if
you're an average American you see more
jobs every month more investment every
month you see Trump doing what he
promised he would do he seems standing
up for America and your choices left
winners who think it's okay to have
thousands of people cross the border
versus protecting America you know in
spy inch Trump is actually organizing
exactly like Andrew Jackson a majority
that I think will get him reelected and
that will actually be decisive in
changing America's future all right so
you wrote a column Mitch McConnell out
there saying no Republicans are gonna
face strong headwinds we hear from
anybody else in the media big blue wave
is coming in November you believe
Republicans can win in November I think
there's a lot at stake not the least of
which applause you become Speaker they
would want to impeach Donald Trump and
they'll make up a reason if they have to
so the question is what are the
Republicans need to do it's April from
now til November to win well let me
remind everyone having spent a lot of my
years as you know as an old friend
campaigning I was behind 51:37 in
September in my third campaign having
lost twice I won that election 5446
George HW Bush was behind in May by 19
points one in November by six that means
one out of every five Americans switched
between May and November now why do I
say that
we're a long way for the 2018 election
if we end up with the anti tax cut
Democrats the anti-semitic Democrats the
socialist Democrats the nut
Democrats the people who have no
positive solution for anything if they
end up being what the issues about we're
gonna win a shocking election if we're
passing slow and stupid and we allow
them to define the election we could
lose so the test for the Republican
Party one of the greatest tests of my
lifetime can we tell a simple clear-cut
story and Trump today in West Virginia
has done a good job again I'm an
old-fashioned tough I'm I believe in
fighting I believe in a real campaign if
we can have a real campaign will do
surprisingly well this fall all right
mr. speaker could to have you back I
know you've been spending a lot of time
your wife obviously is the ambassador
the Vatican and holy seed thank you for
being with us